-Our next guest
is a talented actress
you know from shows
like "The Afterparty"
and "Love Life" and movies like
"Your Place or Mine."
She stars in "Party Down,"
which airs Fridays on Starz.
Let's take a look.
-What's in these?
-Basic sheet cake
done in an on-sale,
store-bought style
with a center
of ripened camembert.
-What?
Wait. What?
-You get an innocent
childlike sweetness up front
followed by an earthy whiff
of decay.
-Why?
-It's a rumination on mortality.
-Rumination on mortality?
It's cake.
-Birthday cake.
-Please welcome to the show
Zoe Chao, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome to the show, Zoe!
-Thanks for having me!
-This is a very exciting
reboot of a show,
or I guess
it's an extension of a show
that came out 10 years ago,
"Party Down."
This is about artists
who work as caterers.
You had a career, as did I,
in the food-service industry.
-Yes.
-Did it bring back flashbacks?
-Oh, yeah.
I started to have
restaurant nightmares again.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Specifically, did I fire
the almond-crusted sea bass
for table 42?
Which I thought
I had left that behind.
-No.
-But it was a triggering
and cathartic exercise
filming season three.
-I had a longer
tale of nightmares
from being a waiter
than any other stressful job
I've ever had.
-Truly.
-I still have -- did you ever --
What was the worst thing
that happened to you
when you were working
in a restaurant?
-Oh, man.
Um...
Okay.
Well, I accidentally fired --
put in -- four burgers
instead of four steaks.
-Big mistake.
-Huge mistake.
-Yeah.
-Pricey mistake that I would
have had to pay for.
I somehow intercepted
the food runner
before he took the four burgers
to the table.
And I was like, "You know what?
I got this.
I really believe in, like,
continuity of service."
[ Laughter ]
And then I had the four burgers,
and I was like, "What do I do?"
And the manager
was in one doorway.
The chef was in another doorway.
And the only -- my only option
was the valet entrance.
-Uh-huh.
-So, I took them out to valet...
-Okay.
-And I put them under a car.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I came back up.
As I was coming back up
from putting them under the car,
the manager had come outside
and was like,
"Yo, Zoe, what are you
doing out here?"
And I was, like, "Um...
Oh, I got gas."
[ Laughter ]
I got some gas.
Didn't want to release it
in front of the customers.
So just came out here
to do a little toot.
Going back to work.
Going back to work."
-So, what was your plan --
long-term plan --
with the burgers under the car?
-Well, three hours later...
-Uh-huh.
-...I went back out to see
if they'd been run over.
And they miraculously hadn't.
So, I took them out, I ate one,
and gave three to my co-workers,
and I've never had
a better burger.
-Wow.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's amazing.
Do you --
And now when you make a burger,
do you leave it under a car for
three hours before you eat it?
-[ Laughs ]
-Just 'cause you like --
No, you're like, "It really
has this nice oily taste."
-Exactly.
No, but I should try that.
-Now, you --
this is a show, again,
about artists who work
in the food-service industry.
-Yeah.
-You were an art history major?
Is that right?
-I was.
-Before you became --
decided on the path of acting?
-Yes.
-So, what sort of things
did you -- was that
what you were pursuing?
Were you, like,
interning in that world?
-I was. So, my parents
are both visual artists.
My sister is a visual artist.
So I thought, "Okay.
I'll be an art history major,
and maybe I'll wind up
in a gallery or a museum."
So, the summer before
my senior year of college,
I worked for this
non-for-profit art gallery
on this project
called Karaoke Ice.
-Okay.
-Which -- bear with me.
It was a vintage car -- truck,
turned into
a traveling karaoke mobile.
-Okay.
-M.C.'d by a mute squirrel cub.
-That would be played
by an actor.
-Okay.
A human actor?
-A real live human actor.
-Dressed like a squirrel?
-Who would wear the squirrel
helmet and the squirrel tail,
drive the truck
into social happenings
all across L.A., like
the Hollywood Bowl, Chinatown.
And then lure, without words,
people into
the back of the truck.
[ Laughter ]
-Uh-huh.
I'm really sorry I missed this.
[ Laughter ]
-With an ice pop.
-Oh!
-So, there was a food component.
And then --
And then you would --
Then, hopefully, the participant
would pick a song,
and it would be
a contemporary pop song
that was translated into
something called tinkle pop,
which is ice-cream-truck music.
So, if you picked, like,
Missy Elliott's "Work It,"
it sounded like...
♪ Doot-doot doot do,
doot-doot do do ♪
♪ Doot-doot do do
doot-doot doot-doot ♪
Yeah, so, I had
to hold auditions for two weeks
to find this mute squirrel cub.
[ Laughter ]
-So, what --
So you're holding auditions,
actors are coming in,
and you're having to explain
what you just explained to us.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
You think
I'd be better at it now.
-I don't think there's
a better way to do it
than you just did it.
-Thanks, Seth.
-I think that was --
I mean, I think, at some point,
the artist might have to answer
some follow-ups, but not you.
-Right, okay, okay. Cool.
-So, what would you look for
in actors who wanted to be
the mute school -- the moot --
the mute luring squirrels?
-Right.
Um, rodent tendencies?
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
-Like, I think -- I think --
I mean, well, I was, 20 --
-Yeah.
Right, you need to be, like, 40
before you know
what makes a good squirrel.
[ Laughter ]
-Exactly.
And so I --
Sometimes they'd ask for notes.
And I'd be like,
"Um, more...rabid."
[ Laughter ]
So, I don't know, but we --
And then, finally, I was like,
"I could do this."
-Oh!
-I was like, "I could be
the mute squirrel cub."
-And did you?
-No, because I had
to go back to school.
-Gotcha.
But do you think this is
when you decided that maybe art
wasn't for you?
-Yes, Seth.
-Wow.
-So, I went home,
and I told my parents,
"I'm gonna be an actor."
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I'm sure once you
explained it to them like that,
they were like, "Absolutely."
-Yes.
-Hey, you know this obviously
is "Party Down," but I also want
to commend you for -- you got
to work with Reese Witherspoon.
-Oh, man.
-In her new rom-com
"Your Place or Mine."
How exciting was that
to be a co-star with somebody
of her stature?
-It was too exciting.
It was kind of terrifying.
-Yeah.
-She's so dreamy
and has not aged.
So, I'm looking at the person
that I grew up with, you know,
who is just, like,
America's sweetheart.
And every scene was with her.
And I was terrified
the entire time.
[ Laughter ]
Sweaty palms.
-Well, it certainly does not
show on the screen.
And it's been so lovely
to have you here.
Thank you so much
for joining us.
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys, that's Zoe Chao.
"Party Down"
airs Fridays on Starz.